canon talk about how you and drama
initially linked up like your guys's
history
uh we linked up in college a good story
because i went to
i used to uh kick it with my man jabari
harris
all right and jabar is one of my closest
people in philly he wasn't coming to
atlanta to school
and i was he was like yo when you get
down there it's a kid named
drum he's dope you need to get with him
he's already
with the roots and and um and bahamadi
and just working with him shout out to
muhammad man shout out to
and uh he was like you make beats y'all
should hook up and my whole thought
process like he next to the roots
oh how about the quarterbacks you know
what i was saying
so i came to school i met him on a
pronoun one time and i and i gave him
some beats and i think
he took it home and he came back was
like yo your beat's hard you need to
come by the crib
you know and work on some [ __ ] and we
just we went to the crib
and worked on some stuff i think he was
you know uh rest in peace to jackson
um and them guys
but he was just like flooding my beats
to people you know what i mean
he was like actually he was the form he
was my managers now i remember like you
know i mean
and at that time he was making beats
also if you could find that 32 beat cd
that's a classic if you find his 32 bcd
but uh yeah
he was making beats i was making beats
and we was just we was just kicking [ __ ]
man
it was times where i i i actually got
kicked out of school right and i ain't
telling my mom
she knows now but i got i got kicked out
of school and i ain't had no place to
live and he kind of took me in wow like
you know for a little bit and i would go
back and forth between him as uh
trent said i had a duplex and i would go
back a fourth day crib if i got on his
nerves
you go over there vice versa so until i
got my you know
my stuff together so you know we we went
to the club he was djing clubs i started
going to club with him
and you know taking the crates and just
filling in doing different things
and also uh you know when we was making
the mixtapes we just was you know
putting the stuff
together at the crib um it got
you know it was just his his crib was
the hub i keep saying uh
532 glen iris like that was the hub it
was just the shack where
you know he had a nice little room any
and everybody was in there t.i was
rapping in the bathroom
scrappy came by little john came by
anybody you think of two chainz
monica you know what i mean wow it just
was in this crib
and it was just the place to be so i
wouldn't want to be nowhere else he had
the records he had like a whole wall
of records you know i was saying dusty
little crib too
yeah it was the best everything no it's
not even like a nice condo or nothing
like
it's dusty she was in the hood yeah
go to music until it's time to you know
disperse and you know
and play our role with those you know